MANO MARKS: Hi.
I'm Mano Marks.
LUKE MAHE: And I'm Luke Mahe.
MANO MARKS: And we're on the
Maps Developer Relations Team.
LUKE MAHE: And we're here to
talk to you about Getting the
Other Mapping Platform, Getting
Your Maps Into iOS.
MANO MARKS: So back in December,
we released the
Google Maps for iPhone, an
application that allowed you
to use the Google Maps app
directly on the iPhone, and it
was a major update
to Google Maps.
Much like we had on Android,
the Google Maps app on the
iPhone used vector rendering to
deliver a really powerful,
immersive experience in Maps
that you could view Google
Maps data on top of.
Now when we released it, as
soon as we released it, we
actually released an SDK
because developers were
clamoring for it right away.
And the reason was because it
allowed them to embed Google
Maps data and Google Maps
services on top of their
applications.
And it took advantage of the
same rendering engine that we
used in the Google Maps iPhone
application to render data
within the SDK.
So we basically got
all that for free.
LUKE MAHE: So when we launched
the SDK in December of 2012,
we launched a limited preview.
But then in January of 2013,
we launched publicly.
And as you can see, we've
had about two
releases every month.
And today, as was announced in
the keynote, we have a special
Version 1.3 release, where we're
going to have some cool
features to show off.
MANO MARKS: Yes, and we'll
get to that later.
LUKE MAHE: We're not going to
tell you exactly how to get
started because there's
some documentation.
You can go to
developers.google.com/maps and
have a read up.
We'll talk a little bit about
what to do with the SDK, but
we're not going to talk to you
about how to download and get
all that little stuff going.
MANO MARKS: So the first thing
to note is that the Google
Maps SDK is a static library.
It's a framework that you
download and incorporate
directly into your
applications.
This gives you some
advantages.
That is, if we make an update to
the SDK, you don't have to
update immediately.
You can take time to evaluate
the update and change your
code, and change it in
your next release.
Therefore, your app will
continue to work.
Although we will give you a
warning if you're developing
in Xcode and using the
simulator, we will log a
warning that says, by the
way, there's another
version of the SDK.
On the other hand, the basic
services that were working
will continue to work, and the
Maps themselves will continue
to update as we get new
Map data, much like
all the other platforms.
LUKE MAHE: We also have a notify
group that you can
join-- which you can find a link
on our Developer site--
and that's where we will
email you every
time we do a release.
And so you can actually get
notified of when to go and
download the new SDK, what's
changed, and then what do you
need to do.
MANO MARKS: Right.
So there's a little bit of
confusion about this on Stack
Overflow and various developer
communities that there's a bit
of myth around Storyboards.
Google Maps SDK does actually
work with Storyboards, unlike
some people think
that it doesn't.
We are very happy to develop
with Storyboards, and that's,
personally, my favorite way
of developing a UI.
When you go into Interface
Builder, you simply create a
new view, and then you make
it of type GMS MapView.
And then that allows you to do
any of your normal sort of
delegating and flow through
that you might do using
Storyboards.
LUKE MAHE: You can also add a
UI view and set that type to
be a GMS MapView as well, and
then you can resize it and do
all the things you're kind of
used to when playing with
Storyboards.
MANO MARKS: Right.
LUKE MAHE: I'll show
you a little bit of
super simple code.
For those who are coming from
JavaScript Maps, this might be
a little different.
We've now got what's called a
camera, and I'll show you a
bit more about a camera later
on because I find it really
fascinating.
There are all the cool things
you can do with it.
But what we do is we create a
camera, add a latitude and
longitude and the zoom level,
and then we instantiate a new
map with that camera
and a size.
Here we're doing a req 0, but
because it's UI view, it'll
fill up the whole view.
And then we create a marker,
where we add it to the map by
setting map equals mapView.
If you've come from some other
mobile mapping APIs, you may
be used to asking the map to add
things to the markers to
the map for you.
But with the way we're doing
this, it's kind of following
what we've done in JavaScript
v3, where you have a marker
and then you just tell
it what map to be on.
So if you want to have multiple
maps and then just
move that marker around,
you can.
MANO MARKS: And this allows you
to do interesting things,
like you can do your own
marker management.
So say you wanted to create two
separate arrays of markers
or dictionaries that had
different properties
associated with different
markers, this would allow you
to implement that kind of
thing, say, a cluster
management tool or something
like that, within your code.
LUKE MAHE: We should talk a
little bit about the features.
MANO MARKS: Right.
Let's talk about the features.
It's a map, and these are some
of the basic features that you
expect when you get
a map, right?
You want to put a marker
on your map.
I think pretty much on any web
application, any SDK, you'd
expect that, right?
We also have polylines.
Again, pretty basic.
Here you can see we have a demo
of the polyline that goes
across the International
Date Line.
It's a geodesic, so it follows
the curvature of the globe
instead of the direct
Mercator line.
And then we also
have polygons.
And of course, all of these
overlays support touch events.
LUKE MAHE: We also
have the camera.
So with the camera, I'll
actually get into more detail
later on about the camera.
But we can show you, we
can have the camera.
We can control it.
We also have a traffic layer.
Obviously, this isn't a live
feed because if it was, around
Moscone it would just be red.
And we also have Compass
and My Location.
So the Compass is where you can
re-rotate the map back to
pointing to north.
And then My Location will just
move the map to where the user
actually is.
And we have all the map types
you're used to enjoying.
We've got road maps.
We've got satellite maps.
We've got hybrid, which is a
combination of satellite with
the layers on top.
And we also have our
terrain maps.
MANO MARKS: Right.
So these are the basic map types
that you would expect in
any Google Maps app.
It's used the same map data
that you would get in the
JavaScript Maps API, on
maps.google.com, and the
Android API.
And we also have the largest
imagery collection in the
world that is available on all
three platforms, as well as
our terrain layer.
We also, by the way, if you
don't want to use the SDK, we
do have a URL scheme that allows
you to open up-- if you
use this URL scheme, you can
open up the Google Maps for
iPhone application if it
exists on the device.
Or you can use the same URL
to then send a query to
maps.google.com if the
app does not exist.
LUKE MAHE: So I said I'd talk a
bit about the camera because
I find it really fascinating,
being able to do all the
interesting things.
With the camera now, we've got
this thing called a target.
So if you're coming from the
JavaScript Maps, this is what
would be something like
your map's center.
But instead, we call it a
target, and this is where
you're looking at
on the world.
So you can use the target to
look down and move it around.
We also have a bearing.
So the bearing is the
rotation of the map.
So you can rotate the map
between zero and 360 degrees,
with zero being north.
And you can see as
the map rotates,
the labels move nicely.
They get out of the way or
they just kind of shift
around, and that's all taken
care of for you.
We also have the
viewing angle.
So the viewing angle is the
angle at which you're looking
at your target.
So you can see here, we're kind
of tilting the camera to
look at the Earth at
a different angle.
So if your angle is zero, you're
looking straight down.
And you can tilt it to about 45
degrees, and then you can
get a really cool perspective
of the Earth.
MANO MARKS: And then you see
the 3D building zoom out of
the map when you
get that close.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
And we also have a zoom.
And because it's all vector
data, we can do this really
nice smooth zooming
in and out.
We also have the discrete zoom
levels that you're used to, so
we've got to zoom level
two, three, four.
But you can also go to
2.6, 9.12, and have
little bits in between.
MANO MARKS: Not 9.12 because
nobody goes there, right?
[LAUGHS]
LUKE MAHE: And then you can
do, like, really cool,
interesting things.
And then see, as we zoom more
into the map and can get close
to the Earth, the 3D
buildings appear.
And then as we zoom out, the
3D buildings go away.
And then combining all these
things, you can do really
interesting implementations
on your map.
So you can see here, as we move
into Melbourne, we kind
of rotate the map.
We're angling down a bit more
to get more perspective of
what we're looking at.
And then as we get closer,
the 3D buildings
grow out of the ground.
And we're also kind of shifting
to where the camera
is looking and then kind
of moving around.
And then we could just
sit there and
look at this all day.
MANO MARKS: And as Luke said,
this is all because we have
these vector-based maps.
We're basically passing map data
down to the SDK, and the
SDK is rendering it on the fly
in the position, the angle,
the bearing, the zoom,
everything
that you want to have.
LUKE MAHE: And these are all
programmatically done at the
moment, but we also have all of
these controls in gestures
for when the user's actually
interacting with your
application.
So we have what you're
used to.
You can pinch to zoom.
You can kind of fling and have
a little bit of inertia.
You can use the two
fingers to tilt.
And then go in more, and then
you get your 3D buildings, and
you can rotate around
and kind of move.
And it's all the things that
you're used to in a maps
application, and especially in
a Google Maps application.
MANO MARKS: So we also
have something new.
We promised this to you
at the beginning.
We're now delivering a
new feature in the
Maps SDK as of today.
Version 1.3 of the SDK
has tile overlays.
So tile overlays are the ability
to add your own map
tiles on top of our maps, or
in the case of this one, in
place of our maps, and we will
then use the SDK to render
those map tiles.
And in this case, we're using
raster tiles and then putting
them on top of our vector data
that's already been rendered.
And you can see here, this is
estimates of geothermal
capabilities in the
United States.
So these are where we believe
there are reservoirs of
geothermal energy in the US.
And the previous one was
actually the World at Night,
the NASA Black Marble data.
And we believe this is a really
tremendously powerful
way for you to bring in
your own kind of data.
And some examples are, you may
use this for generating heat
maps or showing off old maps
scanned from sort of
historical map archives.
And this last feature basically
brings us to feature
parity with the Android API.
LUKE MAHE: A little
bit of code here.
We don't want to show too much
code, but we wanted to show
you how simple it is to add a
tile overlay to your map.
All you're doing is requesting
a URL with a x, a y, and a
zoom value, and then we will
request that and we'll put in
the right spot.
So here we create just a block
that takes these values and
returns a URL string--
I mean an NSURL.
And then we pass that to the
tile layer, and then we add
that tile layer to the map.
MANO MARKS: So let's
talk a moment about
extending the platform.
So Google Maps has a ton of data
that we provide to you,
aside from what's provided
directly through the SDK.
We have a number of different
web services that you can use
to add data, regardless of
what platform you're
displaying the map on.
And because these are Google
Maps, you can use them to
display this Google data.
LUKE MAHE: The first one I like
to show off is Places.
So we've got a Places API, which
has access to millions
of points of interest
around the globe.
And we can do searches for it,
and then get more rich
information to add
to your map.
So here we did a search
for Mexican
food around San Francisco.
And then, based on all the
points that came back, I
tapped on one, and then I could
load more information
about that.
So here we're just getting
a bunch of photos.
We can flick through.
We can get the name, but we
can also get reviews, the
address, and other interesting
information about that.
We also have a couple
of other searches.
We've got your Nearby search.
We've got Radar search.
And we've got a query-complete
implementation for you.
MANO MARKS: Autocomplete.
LUKE MAHE: Autocomplete, yes.
Here's a bit of code.
Don't be too scared
about this.
We're just doing a asynch
request with a URL.
All the web services we're going
to show you kind of are
going to follow the
same fashion.
You do a request, and
you can ask for JSON
or XML to come back.
And then based on the data that
comes back, we can loop
through and then we can add
the markers to a map.
MANO MARKS: So another key
service that we don't provide
directly in the SDK, but we do
provide on a web service, is
the Directions API.
And in this sample, what we're
showing you is the ability of
the Directions API to adjust,
depending on the number of
waypoints that you want
to put in between.
So if you've heard of the
travelling salesman problem,
we basically help you solve
that by taking a starting
location and an ending location,
and then if you
throw waypoints at us and tell
us to optimize the route, we
will find the fastest
route between them.
We allow, in the free API, up to
eight waypoints, aside from
the start and end location.
And in the Maps API for
Business, we allow up to 23.
So this is, again, a really nice
way to give information
to your users, and it's
quite snappy.
LUKE MAHE: And so in the same
fashion as the Places API, we
just do a URL request, the URL
Fetch, essentially, to the
Directions API.
And what I want to point out
here is what we're getting
back is an encoded polyline
as part of the request.
And the encoded polyline, you
might think it's like my cat
walked across the keyboard.
But it's actually the way
we encode polylines.
So instead of having a whole lot
of latitude and longitude
points, we can just send a
string down and then decode
that and then put the
path on the map.
MANO MARKS: Right.
You actually do get direct
access to all the coordinate
pairs if you want those.
We can also, through the SDK,
re-encode polylines if you
want to use them here or,
perhaps, store an encoded
polyline or pass it to somebody
who might be using it
in the JavaScript Maps API.
So we also do geocoding.
Geocoding is the art of taking
an address or a place and
turning it into a
latitude/longitude pair.
So here, it's actually
pretty simple.
We're seeing-- well,
of course, Perth.
You did Perth, didn't you?
LUKE MAHE: It's the best
place in the world.
MANO MARKS: So we start with
Perth and demonstrate Perth.
And as you can see, it just
returns back the geocode.
And then the next one is Paris,
which always looks good
on a big screen.
So a very simple method
of getting a
latitude/longitude pair.
And we will actually, if the
result is not 100% clear,
we'll pass back to you
some alternatives,
should you ask for them.
LUKE MAHE: Also on
the platform we
have reverse geocoding.
So it's the implementation of
taking the latitude and
longitude pair and actually
converting it to an address.
Here's a bit of code where we
can set up a handler for when
someone actually taps
on the map.
And then when someone taps on
it, we send off a request to
do a reverse geocode.
And then based on the result,
we'll put a marker on a map.
MANO MARKS: So this is actually
built in to the SDK,
pretty standard on a
lot of platforms.
So let's talk a little bit about
making these maps your
own and jazzing them up using
some capabilities that are
built in to the platform
as well as the SDK.
LUKE MAHE: So the first one
I want to show is marker
animations.
So in the iOS app that we
launched, we had these marker
animations where the marker just
kind of grew out of the
ground, and we thought
that was really cool.
So we decided to add
it to the SDK.
So as you can see here, when a
marker is added to the map, it
kind of pops up out of the
ground, which is a really good
way of drawing attention to the
piece of information that
you've just added to the map.
We also have the ability
to color our
markers, the default markers.
You don't actually have to
supply a new image every time.
You can use our base image, but
you can change the hue and
saturation and alpha
values to have it
colored however you want.
MANO MARKS: This is a change for
those of you who may have
started with the SDK when we
first released it, where we
only had the default
red marker.
LUKE MAHE: So you can see here,
I've got a little magic
function which will return me
a random value for the hue.
But then based on that, I can
create a marker, and then I
just set the icon
to be the color.
And I also set the animator to
be yes, and then it will grow
out of the ground when it
gets added to the map.
I also want to talk about
Core Animation.
So you can see all these
demos that had
really nice camera movement.
It wasn't just a standard move
from A to B. I use Core
Animation for a lot of these
to be able to define that I
would like the camera values
to move from one specific
value to another one.
And I can define the style of
curve of animation that I'd
like and also what kind
of values I want.
So you can see here, I've got
a little tour that flies
around the world on my next trip
that I'd like to go to.
And then what we're
doing is I'm just
zooming out the camera.
And then as I go between two
locations, I can actually ease
in and ease out and then move
the thing, and I have a marker
that flies in.
So a little bit about
the code.
This is not too scary as well.
We can use the curve, the
animation timing curve.
So here I'm defining an ease
in and ease out function.
And then using that, we can
actually create an animation.
And for here, I'm actually
saying I'd like the latitude
key to be animated over five
seconds, I'd like to use this
curve, and I'd like to move it
to this value, and then we add
it to that.
The same thing as goes with the
keyframe animation, but
here we can define
steps of values
we'd like to go through.
And we can do this for the
latitude and longitude and
zoom, bearing, and
camera angle.
MANO MARKS: So the final thing
is, you might have seen this
during the opening when we
were actually introducing
ourselves, the little puzzle
that solves itself.
And actually, I'm going
to challenge you.
I want you to do this
on the phone.
This is actually an app.
It looks like it's something
that we just created.
But I'm going to challenge Luke
to try and actually--
LUKE MAHE: No.
MANO MARKS: You don't know.
LUKE MAHE: There's a reason--
MANO MARKS: Neither of us can
actually solve that puzzle.
But that actually is an
application, and it takes
advantage of, again, taking
advantage of the iOS platform
and its ability to
generate images.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
So what we can do is we can
use this render in context
method to actually render an
image of the map as it is in
its current state and then
return a UI image with that.
So if any of you have seen this
thing where you've got
fancy, folding maps, where it
comes in from the side and you
just pull it out, they're
usually going to use the same
idiom because that's kind of how
it's done on the platform.
And so using this method, we
can actually extend the
platform so you can actually do
interesting things with it.
And as long as it kind of ends
up as a Google map that you
can interact with, then
that's really cool.
MANO MARKS: Right.
So we hope that what we've been
able to show you in this
presentation is how you can
take advantage of both the
native iOS platform as well as
Google Maps and some of our
Google services to generate a
really rich and also very
familiar experience to your
users, where your users are
looking at a Google map, which
is what most of them will be
expecting to see pretty
much for any map.
And you take advantage of our
rich amount of data and
imagery that you can incorporate
into your own
application.
So to get started,
developers.google.com/maps for
our developer documentation.
We also do Google Maps
Developer Live.
So part of the Google Developer
Live program, just
do /live/maps.
And often it's Luke or I doing
a little five minute--
five or 10-minute map shortcut
on iOS issues.
So thanks very much, everyone,
for coming.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
MANO MARKS: -you can, of course,
find us on Google+.
So we'll take questions now.
If you want to ask a question,
please come up to the
microphone, and we will take
the question there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Alex from HTC.
And I'm wondering--
so the previous slides about
rendering into your image.
Is it possible to point top
left geocoordinate and the
bottom right and zoom level
and render exactly, not
exactly as the screen,
but something bigger?
LUKE MAHE: No, you can't.
That's not possible.
AUDIENCE: No, it's
not possible.
LUKE MAHE: But you could do
something interesting by using
the projection object to kind
of work something out
if you wanted to.
But obviously, you can't take
that image and store it and
keep it forever.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Sort of on a similar
note, is there a way to do the
Render an Image and get an image
of a map, but do it on a
background thread?
So if you had like a
quickly-scrolling UI, and you
wanted to like put a map inside
of that scrolling UI or
something, to be able to, like,
have it render on a
background thread so
you don't block--
LUKE MAHE: No.
Currently, the map runs in
the UI thread, so there's
currently no way
of doing that.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Two questions related
to availability with
this new API that's
out there--
the offline maps feature and
Maps Engine Layer or Map Data
layer-- are either of those
available in the iOS platform?
LUKE MAHE: Neither of
those are currently
available in the platform.
MANO MARKS: That is correct.
The Google Maps Engine, if you
use that, does have a WMS
output, and that's actually
what we used for this tile
overlay demo.
We used a publicly-available map
in the Google Maps Gallery
for the World at Night, the
so-called Black Marble
imagery, and then generated
WMS tile overlay.
And what was interesting about
that is WMS doesn't come out
exactly how our tile overlay
expects to see it.
And because you can--
LUKE MAHE: Subclass.
MANO MARKS: --implement that,
you can subclass--
thank you, it was, like, I know,
my brain just shut off
there for a second-- because
you can subclass the tile
renderer, you can fudge it so
that that gets the right URL
and pulls it into the
tile overlay.
It works the same way that you
would expect it to work in the
JavaScript or Android app.
LUKE MAHE: You can basically
take the same URLs from
Android and JavaScript
and use them in this.
AUDIENCE: Is that app you had
with the fudging then
available in the GIT Repository
or do you--
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
We'll put that code
up somewhere.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have two questions.
One is about Geofencing.
In the morning you
had some demos, I
think for the Android.
How about for the iOS?
MANO MARKS: Well, so Geofencing
was released as
part of the Google Play
services, which is only
available on Android.
You certainly could implement
it yourself.
I understand it's pretty
battery-intensive to do it yourself.
But currently we don't
have it available in
the Google Maps SDK.
AUDIENCE: Second question is
how about the indoor maps?
MANO MARKS: Indoor maps?
Currently we don't have indoor
maps in the iOS SDK.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thanks.
MANO MARKS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: We need to animate
our markers.
Can we do that with your SDK?
LUKE MAHE: Currently, the only
animation that we actually
have is the grow animation.
We haven't got any other
animations, and you can't
supply your own yet.
AUDIENCE: So we can't supply
new images regularly or--
LUKE MAHE: You can change the
marker image and have whatever
marker image you want if
you want to do that.
Like what sort of animation are
you interested in doing?
AUDIENCE: Well, there's
a few things.
We need to flash some of them,
and we also need some of them
to rotate reasonably often.
So what we can't have is
something that flickers with
destroying and remaking
new ones.
LUKE MAHE: Yes.
You don't actually have to
destroy or remake the marker
because you actually keep a
reference to that marker now.
It's not actually added to the
map and then forgotten about.
You can keep that marker,
and you can keep
changing the icon.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And another question is, can we
add our own vector layers?
LUKE MAHE: Not yet.
AUDIENCE: But, you said yet?
LUKE MAHE: Well, no.
You pushed me.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
MANO MARKS: Luke?
Yeah.
Are there any more questions?
LUKE MAHE: Cool.
MANO MARKS: All right.
LUKE MAHE: Thank
you, everybody.
MANO MARKS: All right,
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]